[Music]
on this Saturday night an historic wind
and heartbreaking loss at the World Cup
Morocco scores an upset becoming the
first African country to ever advance to
the semi-finals
as the Sports World reacts to the sudden
death of a beloved journalist it's a
tragic loss is an unfortunate to lose
someone as great as he was
Hockey Canada concerns as the maritimes
prepares to host the world junior hockey
championship new questions about a
sexual assault investigation involving
the 2003 Canadian team
is anti-Semitism going mainstream people
are no longer saying the quiet Parts out
loud
they are literally screaming them what's
driving the spike in anti-jewish hate
crimes plus the 14 year old phenol who's
taking Canadians snowboarding to new
heights
global national
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
a history-making match in Cotter Morocco
becoming the first African nation to
ever advance to a World Cup semi-final
they defeated Powerhouse Portugal one to
nil pulling off the stunning upset
Jubilation for Moroccans right around
the world including here in Canada
hundreds gathered in Montreal to
celebrate the momentous occasion
good evening and thank you for joining
us that celebratory atmosphere has been
tinged with tragedy American Grant Wall
one of the world's top soccer writers
collapsed while covering the Argentina
Netherlands game on Friday he later died
in hospital Jennifer Johnson has more on
his life and Legacy 48 year old Grant
Wall was surrounded by other journalists
covering the nail biter between World
Cup powerhouses Argentina and the
Netherlands when he collapsed it was
obviously that someone was in trouble
that I didn't know at the times it was
Grant they you know worked with him for
I don't know 20 30 minutes before he was
taken on the stretcher officials say
wall may have suffered a heart attack or
a pulmonary event wall had written
earlier in the week that a cold had
turned into something more severe in his
upper chest medical personnel at the
World Cup had given him antibiotics his
death has shocked many top athletes
including LeBron James who was in high
school when wall first started covering
him anytime his name will come up I'll
always think back to me as a teenager
and having Grant you know in our
building down at St V so it's a tragic
loss wall was attending his eighth men's
World Cup and had high hopes for Team
America I don't think this U.S team
fears any other team in the tournament
wall was often vocal about qatar's laws
Banning homosexuality last month he was
detained upon entering the stadium for
wearing a t-shirt featuring a rainbow
design and refusing to change it U.S
soccer writing Grant's belief in the
power of the game to advance Human
Rights was and will remain an
inspiration to all
and U.S women's national team star Megan
rapino tweeting this is so devastating
there is a great sense of shock you know
you come to a World Cup as a journalist
to work to share the the stresses the
pressures but also the enjoyments and
the fascination of it everybody
recognized that enthusiasm in him
many in the U.S credit wall with
soccer's growth and popularity when he
was covering the game for Sports
Illustrated he built a career reporting
on the sport he loved and died covering
its biggest event
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
Russian State television has aired a
video of Brittany Greiner at a penal
colony shortly before her release
the American basketball star was moved
to mordovia that's about eight hours
southeast of Moscow back in mid-november
the footage shows her working then in
her room and signing papers ESPN reports
that Greiner wasn't able to sow uniforms
with the other inmates because of her
height so she carried fabric all day
Greiner landed back in the U.S on Friday
following a prisoner swap with Russian
arms dealer Victor boot
well the best young players in hockey
are coming to Canada this holiday season
the maritimes is preparing to host the
world junior Championship the tournament
comes against the backdrop of police
investigations now underway into sexual
assault allegations against the Canadian
junior teams from 2003 and 2018. as Ross
Lord reports new questions are now being
asked about the role Halifax Police is
playing in one of those investigations
it's been four months since Halifax
Police started investigating off-ice
allegations of sexual assault met
against some members of the 2003
Canadian world junior hockey team in a
statement the department says it's not
providing details to protect the ongoing
investigation police won't say if
they've interviewed players others
associated with the team or the woman
who was allegedly sexually assaulted
there are new questions about the
investigation based on overlaps in
police and hockey culture I do think
that that is a problem Halifax Regional
Police have a partnership with the
city's Halifax Mooseheads of the Quebec
major Junior Hockey League a one-on-one
Mentor program that according to the
moosehead's website includes police
officers joining the team in group
activities like pistol shooting at a
firing range and players going out on
patrol for a Ride Along this sexual
assault researcher says such
relationships can create something
called empathy where investigators have
more empathy with men who are accused
than with their female complainants
those close relationships through
through that formal mentoring program
with the uh the moose heads
um our our rather problematic and I do
think that Halifax Police should be
examining
um that program specifically given
um you know these allegations uh the
current allegations uh you know that are
being investigated from
2003. when asked of its close
relationship with Junior Hockey helps or
hinders its investigation Halifax Police
replied our objective in all of our
investigations is to ensure the best
possible and most impartial
investigations for its part Hockey
Canada says it's taking steps to make
sure people are protected over the
course of the world juniors saying their
security plan includes enhanced team
rules and increased supervision of
players coaches and staff with a zero
tolerance policy for acts of harassment
discrimination racism and sexual
violence Hockey Canada's success in
Walking The Walk remains to be seen
but along with their concerns victims
Advocates say there's a positive
development growing awareness of how
police have mishandled previous sexual
assault allegations means more pressure
on investigators to get it right
gross Lord Global News Halifax
to Montreal now where the un's cop-15
biodiversity Summit is underway
representatives from nearly 200
countries are meeting to hash out an
international agreement on preserving
the planet's ecosystems but as Mackenzie
gray reports there's growing skepticism
over whether world leaders will be able
to strike a deal
[Music]
hundreds taken to the streets in
Montreal with a clear message for world
leaders
strike a deal to help stop biodiversity
loss
diversity it's an emergency inside cop
15 other delegates taking a different
approach with some rapping
[Music]
and dancing to try and put pressure on
decision makers I'm really concerned not
only for about the future
generation but also for my health and
for the health of my parents 196
countries have sent representatives to
Montreal over 10 000 delegates in total
the focus for the Canadian government
one key goal known as 30 by 30 a target
of trying to protect 30 percent of land
and oceans worldwide by 2030. a lot of
ambition a lot of countries want a
successful outcome here in in Montreal
so I'm that gives me great confidence
that we will be able to to achieve our
goals but that ambition will come at a
cost the United Nations estimating
countries will need to spend a whopping
350 billion dollars annually to help
meet their nature goals over 1 million
species are at risk of Extinction by
2050. unless we start to do something
different about the way we treat our
environment
despite the dire warning negotiations in
Montreal are off to a rocky start three
days of talks failed to deliver a draft
agreement with countries disagreeing on
1400 different items issues around
curbing emissions a deadline for phasing
out pesticides and how poor Nations will
pay for hitting targets all key sticking
points up to now we know that all Global
indicators and targets for nature have
been missed so this is the opportunity
to set a global framework that is
specific and achievable prime minister
Justin Trudeau committed 800 million
dollars toward indigenous-led
conservation projects this week as First
Nation leaders stress their involvement
is crucial to ensure these projects
don't fail Trudeau is one of only a
handful of world leaders expected to
attend the conference which negotiators
have said will make it more difficult to
reach an ambitious deal by the time the
conference wraps up on December 19th
Mackenzie gray Global News
Ottawa
Canada's minister of Natural Resources
unveiled a nearly 4 billion dollar
strategy on Friday aimed at positioning
Canada as a global supplier of critical
minerals lithium Cobalt and other
minerals are essential for many
eco-friendly Technologies they're used
to make batteries for electric vehicles
for example but they also come with
major national security implications our
Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson
sat down with Minister Jonathan
Wilkinson for this week's edition of the
West block to discuss the government's
plan
I was reading through this strategy and
and there's so many mentions of of
National Security and it's easy to kind
of hear uh lithium copper who cares but
there's very serious concerns about
National Security Canada's Energy Future
and it seemed to me like there was a lot
in here that was not so thinly veiled
references to concerns about Russia and
China how how much has what's happened
in recent years with the government in
Beijing and with Russia's war in Ukraine
contributed to your government deciding
you need to do something about critical
minerals to get that supply chain inside
of Canada where we're not relying on
countries like Russia and China to
provide these things
well it certainly had something to do
with it I would say they're kind of two
drivers for this strategy the first is
there is no energy transition without a
significant increase in critical
minerals
um and so Canada needs to do its part
alongside uh some of our allies like
Australia who also are very focused in
this area in order to ensure that not
just Canada but but uh but the world can
actually move through the transition and
fight climate change but the second part
of it is we need to ensure that not just
the minerals but in particular the
processing of those minerals is done in
in locations where we can be secure and
stable in terms of our access to supply
I think the world learned a lot in the
aftermath of the the illegal Russian
invasion of Ukraine where Germany found
itself very much dependent on Russia for
oil and gas I don't think anybody wants
to be in that position on a go forward
basis with critical minerals so it did
certainly inform that I would say you
know if you think about Rare Earth
elements I mean it's between 80 and 90
of those are actually processed right
now in China well that's just from a
national security perspective not some
where we want to go our American friends
want to go our European friends want to
go and so it did help to inform some of
the strategy for sure
for more details on the government's new
minerals strategy plus an interview with
NDP leader jugmeet Singh on gun control
and his party's confidence and Supply
agreement with the Liberals tune in to
the West block this Sunday on global
France offers free condoms for young
people
coming up why Health experts say Canada
should follow the French example
plus alarming anti-Semitism fears
following a spike in anti-jewish hate
crimes
welcome back French president Emmanuel
macron is expanding on a new health
policy announced earlier this week
condoms will now be free in pharmacies
for anyone under the age of 25 expanding
on his earlier promise aimed at those
between 18 and 25. the move is meant to
address a growing problem one that's
also worsening in this country sexually
transmitted diseases and as Mike
Armstrong reports the new French policy
is receiving praise from experts here in
Canada
the French President is calling it a
small Revolution for prevention as of
January 1st in France condoms will be
available free of charge in pharmacies
this woman says it's a good idea and
will help young people who have trouble
paying now the goal is to reverse two
Trends on the one hand use of
contraception is dropping while the
number of sexually transmitted
infections or STIs is growing some
French Health officials call it an
explosion chlamydia cases jumped 15
percent last year in fact since 2015
they've doubled France has already made
condoms free for young people with a
prescription but it didn't appear to be
working
this pharmacist says doctors weren't
prescribing condoms often enough and
right now no one has enough money young
people especially
now the battle against STIs is on here
in Canada as well earlier this month
Atlantic provinces announced an
initiative to make STI testing more
accessible they'll be available at
pharmacies it's a growing problem in
this country as well over the course of
a decade from 2010 chlamydia cases
jumped about 60 percent gonorrhea by
about 175 percent and syphilis by close
to 400 percent Alex McKay is with the
sex information and education Council of
Canada sexually transmitted infections
have always been a much more significant
threat to Public Health than uh much of
the population realizes the case is the
pandemic likely made the problem worse
it wasn't as much STI testing and the
more undiagnosed infections in the
population the easier STIs spread McKay
points out the French government is also
focused on sexual health education the
French are already ahead of uh in many
respects ahead of where we ER so that's
another area uh that we need to focus on
now there has been some criticism of the
free access to condoms policy in France
some argue the government should be
worrying about bigger priorities
my comes from Global News Montreal
fighting against anti-Semitism still
ahead the growing fears that anti-jewish
hatred is becoming all too common
Russia's war in Ukraine was the focus
for this year's Nobel Peace Prize
ceremony the recipients are activists
from Ukraine Russia and Belarus who
condemned moscow's Invasion and called
for international support for Ukraine we
foreign
you don't have to be Ukrainian to
support Ukraine it's enough just to be
human said Nobel Laureate Alexander
matvichuk a Ukrainian human rights
lawyer her co-recipients were a detained
belarussian rights activist who is
represented by his wife and a Russian
Human Rights group
for several years anti-semitic comments
and acts have been on the rise both here
in Canada and in the United States
fueling fears that anti-jewish hate is
becoming normalized the spike is being
blamed on many factors such as social
media politics even celebrities such as
Kanye West as far NASA reports
communities are calling for Action to
confront the troubling trend you will
not replace us
you will not replace us instead of being
universally reviled this day in
Charlottesville more than five years ago
not only bolstered the Neo-Nazi movement
but made it easier for others to say
nothing former president Donald Trump
has refused to disavow sitting at a
dinner with two of the most prominent
anti-semites in the United States one of
them a celebrity with a wide reach it
gives them a sense of freedom to give
full expression to whatever it is that
they're feeling without consequence a
couple that with with the more acute
economic situation and inflation facing
everybody has people looking for a way
to explain it for somebody to blame in
Canada offenses targeting Jews comprised
of 14 of all hate crimes even though the
community makes up one percent of the
population Canada has seen a sharp rise
in anti-semitic incidents in the past
few years and it's the same in the
United States last year 2020 one saw the
highest number of anti-Semitic incidents
ever recorded according to the
Anti-Defamation League the White House
is ramping up its efforts to fight what
it calls an epidemic of hate let me be
clear
words matter
people are no longer saying the quiet
Parts out loud
they are literally screaming them second
gentleman Doug emhoff the first Jewish
spouse of a vice president hosted a
round table with Jewish leaders on
Wednesday including Rabbi Jonah pesner
here in the United States there are more
guns Than People which means that we
have a plague not only of anti-Semitism
and white supremacy we also have a
plague of gun violence including a mass
shooting at Pittsburgh's Tree of Life
synagogue in 2018 killing 11 people we
understand now that the violence that
happens in Pittsburgh led to the
violence that happened in a supermarket
in Buffalo New York which was largely
targeting black people and why because
the murderer believed in that great
replacement lie which says that there's
a global conspiracy of Jews to turn
America black brown and Muslim through
immigration policy and elections what a
hateful kind of evoking of the
centuries-old anti-semitic tropes right
Jews control the banks Jews control
Hollywood back in Canada Shimon Fogle
with the center for Israel and Jewish
Affairs says he's also concerned about
progressives downplaying anti-Semitism
where the argument is that Jews cannot
possibly have experienced discrimination
or hate because they're part of white
privileged
classes of of our society wherever it
comes from experts fear another year
means another increase in hate Farah
Nasser Global News Washington
up next a teenager is taking
snowboarding by storm at the world
championships in Alberta
[Music]
foreign
snowboarders are on the cusp of becoming
world champions tonight on home turf
Mark McMorris and Nicholas lafrombois
will compete in the final of the
snowboard Big Air World Cup the
competition is taking place in Edmonton
and the Canadian athletes say they're
thrilled to compete in their home
country and perhaps no one more so than
a 14 year old Phenom who's carving A New
Path slav kornik reports
[Music]
this is Eli buchard at eight years old
becoming the youngest person to ever
land a double backflip I was young and
didn't know what what was the hive
around this but
yeah and I guess like
it was pretty big so yeah butchard has
been doing big things on a snowboard
since he was first buckled into one when
he was just a year old he's a Phenom in
the sport although he's very humble
about his abilities just been practicing
each year in EJ each each weeks and yeah
just trying to do my best
just shy of his 15th birthday buchard
had to get a special exemption to
compete in Edmonton's Big Air event it's
his first World Cup competition and the
first time he's going up against the
best in the world feels good because I
was watching them as a kid I was trying
to do the same tricks as them looking at
them trying to do my best and now I'm
copying against them so
so amazing
one of butchard's fellow competitors is
his hero three-time Olympic medalist
Mark McMorris who supremely impressed
with the teenager they keep getting
younger it's unbelievable how good they
can be at such a young age and I quite
look forward to watching him and seeing
his performance here pichard is keeping
his goal simple for this weekend he just
wants to land his tricks and have fun
his long-term aspirations though are a
little more lofty he wants to be an
Olympian compete in the X Games and
become one of the best snowboarders in
the world slavkornick global Sports
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
your Canada is Devin Alberta we love
seeing your Canada so please keep
emailing your festive photos to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you back here again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]